[Music]
hi I'm kelcie Hightower a staff
developer advocate for Google cloud
platform and hi I'm Matt hooker an
engineer at hashey Corp working on
Packer alright this is the third video
in a series covering open-source tools
from hashey Corp and how we can use them
with Google cloud platform in the last
video you learn how developers can
create repeatable development
environments with vagrant in this video
Matt and I are going to cover Packer
Matt can't give us an overview of Packer
yeah thanks Kyle so yeah I'd be happy to
Packer may at first seem a lot like
vagrant in the sense that it can be used
to define the software and configuration
for a VM but unlike vagrant the artifact
it produces is a machine image as
opposed to a running VM the machine
image can be used to create VMs
pre-configured exactly how you want them
all through a simple Packer config file
this is where it gets cool with a single
configuration and common specification
Packer can produce almost any machine
image like Google compute engine other
cloud providers and even docker images
yeah Packer is a pretty dope I've used
it in quite a few of my projects and
know a few people using Packer in fact
I'm the original offer of the GCE
builder for Packer going back many years
now nice and I know that ok then you
might have some kind of demo or
something you could show us right now
that's why we're here consuming the
story from last time we want to create a
GC image based on a similar figure saw
in the vagrant video you recall from
that video that Vega was used by
developers but the main goal of creating
their application and sharing across a
vagrant VM on Google now we're going to
start sliding the perspective from our
developer view over to our operations
view where you want to deploy these
images on GCE
for the running the app for our users so
the image we're going to create will
have our 80s style arcade game and its
dependencies installed and configured to
start at boot time
Matt how do we get started let's do it
you want to start by going to Packer dot
IO and downloading the version
appropriate for your platform in the
last video you saw how to set up your
GCP project so we'll skip that part this
time but I think this time we're going
to use a GC instance right Kelsi right I
have a machine called dev that we're
going to use we're going to be using
Packer to create a new GCE operating
system image I'll first show you what we
currently only have the standard GCE
images available to us great now let's
flip over to our terminal on the Devon
sense where I already have Packer
installed and my Packer config file
ready to go let's kick off the image
build process now with the Packer build
command okay now that we've got that
going let's take a look at the
hyperspace jacek config file we're using
packet config files have two primary
parts a section that specifies builders
and another for provisioners in our
builders section you can see that I'm
not only defining the variables needed
to produce the Google compute engine
image I'm specifying attributes such as
the base operating system and the name
of the new image let's take a quick look
at the provisioner section Packer allows
you to customize the image with any
number of provisioner types like basic
shell scripts which is what you see here
or even using other configuration
management tools so it's just chef
puppet ansible etc but back to the topic
of builders Kelsie do you want to
describe how Packer builds an image for
a GCP you bet first Packer spins up a
new instance with the base image that
was described then pack of what SSH into
the new VM and apply any configuration
defined in the provisioning section of
the Packer config here or basically
reusing the shell script you saw in the
vagrant video but split it out into its
own file let's see how the build process
is doing okay looks like it's running
through those provisioning steps and our
shell scripts we'll skip ahead here a
little bit even though I know we all
love watching Debian packages and saw
once the provisioning customizations
have finished Packer will terminate the
running GCE instance but belive behind
the persistent disk or PD as we like to
call it the PD contains the base
operating system
our customizations and is used in a
template to create the new GCE image
once the image is created
Packer deletes the PD so there aren't
any leftover resources in your DCP
project it's finished let's take a look
at the list of images now and sure
enough there's our new hyperspace image
we can even quickly spin up a new GC
instance with our brand new image I'll
click the checkbox next to the image and
click the Create instance button I'll
keep all the defaults but since
hyperspace is a web app I'll enable the
HTTP firewall rule for the instance and
then click create hey Matt while we're
waiting for this new instance come up
let's take a look at the console output
as it's booting you can hit refresh and
see the new console output show up okay
the instance is up let's click on the IP
address to see what happens
BAM now that's dope crate demo Calci
obviously one of the biggest strengths
of Packer is the ability to produce
equivalent images across multiple cloud
providers we definitely hear of
customers that want multi cloud support
so it's been great to see Google
contributing to the project
alright thanks Matt for joining us today
my pleasure it's been a lot of fun all
right thanks everyone for watching don't
forget to subscribe to the channel to
keep up with more the videos in the
series we've got more coming for how you
can use other hashey Corp tools for GCP
also take a look at the description to
see some of the work my colleague has
done on creating automated image builder
using jenkins packer and kubernetes
alright thanks for watching make sure to
check out our last video in a series as
well as a playlist and don't forget to
subscribe